the number of dead in New York is
climbing and the morgues are running out
of space bodies are now being stored in
refrigerated lorries parked outside the
city's hospitals this is another victim
of coronavirus another number to add to
america's growing toll this is one of
New York's biggest hospitals another
ambulance arriving we counted four
chills trucks parked on a side street
next to it which we were told will be
used as makeshift morgues as and when
but probably of course sooner rather
than later
New York is preparing for the worst and
you get a sense now there's a real
inevitability about what comes next the
National Guard is building for emergency
hospitals across the state they are now
planning to construct another four this
is the Javits Center an enormous arena
in downtown Manhattan W a thousand beds
here and it should be up and running in
days from there New York's governor
delivered this powerful rallying cry to
the men and women on the front line
leadership at a time of crisis in ten
years from now you'll be talking about
today to your children or your
grandchildren and you will shed a tear
because you will remember the lives lost
and you'll remember the faces and you'll
remember the names and you'll remember
how hard we worked and that we still
lost loved ones
the first of two hospital ships has now
docked in Los Angeles the second will
arrive in New York on Monday they will
take non-covered 19 patients to help
free up space in the city's hospitals
what is your overall assessment of where
New York City is right now so New York
City is
you know rapidly approaching a place
where we are going to have our hospital
system overwhelmed I'm grateful that the
federal government has come in to start
with this planning effort but honestly
it's going pretty slow and we need to
ramp up the pace at which we're putting
the surge capacity in place the United
States has now overtaken China in the
number of confirmed cases and yet the
president at times still sounds
skeptical if you want an idea of what
they're expecting here just look at the
scale of preparations it's a race
against time and time is running out
Alistair bungled Sky News New York